welcome to the man of recaps this is
house of the dragon episode 5. the
episode begins in the vale where we meet
damon targaryen's wife this whole series
he's talked about her like she's some
awful ugly person but i mean she's kind
of hot and seems real cool but while out
riding she meets a mysterious hooded
figure it is her husband damon and long
story short he's ready to be single
again and he kills her makes it look
like an accident now king viserys has
taken a boat ride with his daughter
rhaenyra they're going to the seat of
house valerian yes it's driftmark in the
castle of high tide remember the
valerians are a huge naval power this
whole series so far the valerians have
almost married into the royal family and
now it's time to do it he's like your
son lane or my daughter raniera now
there's a lot of different things to
consider first of all remember corlis
himself is married to rainey's targaryen
the queen who never was so his kids are
half targaryen but that makes them
distant cousins and he's excited for his
children to be in the royal line the
biggest issue is still the line of
succession will rhaenyra really be queen
or will he pass over her and make his
son aegon king so this marriage is
totally pointless for him but viserys
assures him like he's been doing the
whole series renera is my heir so she
will be queen your son will be king and
your grandkids will be the future rulers
the other question of course are renera
and lenore okay with being married and
yeah they grew up together as cousins
they're friends lenore seems a little
depressed about it but rainier is like
look cuz i know you're gay that's fine
this marriage is a political arrangement
we can be friends and you know bang
whoever we want on the side one of his
knights is leno's red-headed boyfriend
who he loves very much so great news for
him and ranira of course has her secret
boyfriend the king's guard sir kristen
cole he's like hey crazy idea but hear
me out here what if you don't marry lane
or what if you run away from this whole
queen thing you and i can sail to the
free cities marry each other and just
have a nice quiet life and you know
that's a little tempting but rainier is
like no i'm a targaryen i'm gonna be
queen you're okay with being my secret
lover right but sir kristin cole is not
really okay with that you know being a
kingsguard you take a vow specifically
not to bang your princess he likes to
think he's an honorable guy but now he
feels like an awful person so he kind of
breaks things off back in king's landing
otto hightower has just been fired as
hand of the king so he's going home his
daughter allison to the queen is like
dad i don't want you to go in fact it's
kind of her fault he's fired because she
sided with rhaenyra in the whole scandal
of did she sleep with her uncle damon
otto hightower an interesting character
we don't know how much he's scheming and
how much he's just trying to give good
advice but he has some hard advice for
her now like look your best friend
ranira that's not gonna work out if she
takes the iron throne half the realm is
gonna rebel because they don't want a
woman king they're gonna try to put your
son aegon on the throne so to protect
her own claim rhaenyra is gonna have to
kill your kids and this whole succession
crisis might happen sooner rather than
later because king viserys is a real
sick we've seen it little by little
since episode one he's got something
awful and they're trying to leech him
for it and cut off fingers to stop the
spread but it ain't working now the new
hand of the king is lord lionel strong
who was the king's second best advisor
who don't know much about what his deal
is yet he seems like a generic solid
advisor but his son laris strong is
playing the game of thrones much harder
he's a very intelligent observant guy
who now approaches allison like hey is
ranira okay i heard the grand maester
brought her some tea yes remember that's
the plan bt he made just in case and now
allison's like wait did rainer lie to me
and did bang damon so watch out for lara
strong here he's a stir in the pot so as
soon as everyone gets back allison sets
to interrogating sir kristen goal now
she's just trying to ask him if as her
near his bodyguard he saw anything with
her and damon but she doesn't say damon
she's like i heard a rumor the queen got
laid the other night and he's feeling
guilty so he instantly confesses alice
and ty tower with the epic poker face
like don't say anything just let him
keep talking he's like i broke my oath
i'm a terrible person you should have me
executed but she's like that won't be
necessary right now so now just a little
later it's wedding time and all the
lords of the realm are here for the
party it all seems like it'll go
smoothly but weddings and game of
thrones never do first problem is when
damon shows up who was not invited but
he seems to be on good behavior so
viserys doesn't kick him out the next
drama is when queen allison walks in
late she waited until right in the
middle of vasara's speech she's looking
great in her green dress but lara strong
points out when her family the high
towers go to war they light the beacon
green yet she is not happy anymore feels
like her friend ranira betrayed and lied
to her and her father's advice is sunk
in she's ready to get ahead of this
probable civil war then damon's wife's
cousin comes to be like yo bro i know
you killed her but he's like you can't
prove it gtfo and damon's jumping right
into that single life again when he goes
after lena valerian the young girl who
the king almost married but is now
mostly grown up they flirt pretty hard
she's totally down with it but then
neyman goes for a dance with her era
like hey what are you marrying this guy
for you should be marrying me but she's
like uncle you had your shot with me and
left me hanging like are you all talk
you're gonna kidnap me right now
meanwhile lenore and his boyfriend are
wondering whoever near a secret lover is
and it's super obvious it's kristin cole
so red hair goes over there like hey man
let's be friends we're going to be
spending a lot of time together if i'm
banging the king and you're banging the
queen but kristin cole is not chill with
this he was already feeling bad about it
and this guy figured it out in one
second now suddenly there's a ruckus on
the dance floor what's happening no one
knows turns out it's kristin cole
attacking red hair how he kills him
beats him to death why did he do it well
it's complex of course it doesn't make
sense logically but i think he was
feeling real guilty and when this guy
approached him about it he's just like
lashed out nasser kristen feels even
guiltier so he goes out to the godswood
he's gonna kill himself but queen
allison is there to stop him like hey
man don't you still got a part to play
this obviously puts a damper on the
party so they rush the wedding forward
to make sure it's official before any
more shenanigans happen he and janira
were so close to having a happy
political marriage while they had their
lovers on the side but instead it's a
heartbreaking scene as young laner sobs
through his vows they didn't even clean
up the blood yet and that's where house
of the dragon episode 5 comes to an end
if you like this recap hit that
subscribe button for more of the best
recaps of tv and movies
[Music]